what's up theo this is your boy brian
coming at you from uh st petersburg
florida
oh brian and saint petersburg dude it's
a good place to get a
final buried treasure maybe see a damn
tattooed tit bro
[ __ ] yeah come on homework
and i was just listening to your round
italians episode
and you were talking about going to bj's
pizza
when you were a kid with your family and
you you asked us
if we had any memories growing up of
always going to an eatery
i grew up in the suburbs of chicago and
we'd go to this pizza place called papa
pacero
oh papa paceros huh let's hear more
about this
about this beautiful spot
and you would think because chicago is
good pizza but but very similar to your
bj's
incident uh the pizza sucked man but i
know they had cheap beer so my parents
and my aunts and uncles would go out on
a friday night we'd all get beer and
pizza and they had a big old arcade
and they'd send us into the arcade which
was some quarters be playing mortal
kombat and all the games
and the one memory i had to stuff out is
this one boy i don't know his name
but he would always dominate the mortal
kombat machine
and he would keep his quarters in his
mouth so it was the strangest thing and
he'd get done beating somebody
flawless victory with scorpio and he'd
spit out like a little lizard spit out a
couple quarters
throw them back in the machine say who's
next damn man and that's a sign usually
of uh
eating disorder you know that could be
some type of eating disorder maybe um
but yeah every arcade had some kid at it
that you didn't know from your town
you're like who
there's only 40 kids in town i knows
them all
and who is this magic man some little
fella named laser or some
every arcade had some weird ass kid that
you've never seen before
who was always winning all the games and
doing this and that
dude i was always the weirdo at arcade
where i would like i'd have to check
every little thing
then i'd go outside and check the
newspaper machine see if they had a
quarter
and then um sometimes the video game
somebody would have dropped a quarter
and it would have got stuck
under so i'd look under there sometime i
get a piece of paper and fold it over
about four times make me a paper stick
make me a stick but out of paper it's
almost like
because a paper was a stick so really
you just doing some damn
it's almost like when you see a
mannequin made out of actual human body
parts you're like damn okay this is
you know this is back back fourth and
fourth you know what i'm saying this is
refurbishment
but um but i'd make a paper stick and i
would try to slot
reach under the machine and see if
there's because there's only about an
eighth of an
inch there and it was dust in there it's
nasty
they usually have a little runt or a
little gumball down there
and i would slide that paper trying to
knock a quarter out the end
or look behind the machine there was a
button behind the machine sometimes you
could press it it would turn the machine
on and off and i would always like wait
for it to come on and think it was gonna
let me have a free game and it wouldn't
and then there was always the person
that would sit there and watch you play
all the games that dude
that kid whoever that kid was a little
benji or a little tragic
we had a little black kid bus named
tragic right
and man he was he never had a damn dime
bro he sit there and watch you play you
know why he wouldn't say nothing bro
damn he wouldn't say no i don't know if
he ever even said nothing
he might still be just looking at
something
but um
what else what'd you say man yeah it was
fun though the video games was a big
part
and i would get what was that game super
ice brothers let me see
super ice super
ice bros no that wasn't it
yeah super maybe it was smash brothers
but it was an old one
i thought it was ice bros
yeah there was some game just i don't
even know some of the games were just so
old
oh castlevania and you get to you know
it's like
i don't know what it was it was like
some guy that was like kind of like
it was like zillow for vampires it was
like some guy that was looking for
a castle i guess i don't remember he
you know he just couldn't really find
i don't remember what it was it was like
fi i don't remember if the place had a
draw
he didn't lie what he was fighting but
you were
he had a whip and you were angry at the
realtors and you were like looking for a
nice castle but you couldn't find what
you wanted
um you know you'd be in like a 60
bedroom castle and you'd be pissed off
them yeah
just i don't know i wasn't real good at
it but mom or dad give you that quarter
and you go ah when you put that quarter
in just the feeling you had
i got a chance all right hit the buttons
a couple times before the game starts
move the joystick
man it was fun that was a good time
thank you for the call as always the
hotline 985-664-9503
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one